Hallo und herzlich willkommen beim Easy German
Podcast! Für die, die ihn nicht kennen: Wir machen
dreimal in der Woche einen Podcast und jetzt seit
einiger Zeit auch so ungefähr einmal im Monat live
auf YouTube. Und heute sind wir wieder live auf
YouTube, aber Cari ist heute leider nicht dabei,
sie entschuldigt sich. Dafür haben wir aber
endlich mal wieder Janusz im Podcast. (Hallo!)
Okay, die Motivation ist hoch, das ist gut. Hi!
(Hi!) Was hast du dir zu trinken mitgebracht?
Zum Beispiel ein Apfel-Holunderblüte.
Oh. Markennamen muss man eigentlich
überkleben im Fernsehen, ne? Wir sind …
Okay, Entschuldigung.
… nicht gesponsert von dieser Marke.
Ich glaube, die haben auch kein
Werbebudget. Es war die Marke "ja!", die
Janusz gerade in die Kamera gehalten hat.
Und dann auch meinen leckeren
Kaffee natürlich, ja.
Natürlich, obwohl es schon sieben Uhr abends ist.
Der Kaffee ist koffeinfrei und dann noch
ziemlich dünn, also ziemlich schwach, ja.
Ja, schön. Okay. Ich habe meinen Tee
dabei und wir haben heute ein sehr,
sehr schönes und interessantes …
Und dieses Thema lautet: Feste und Feiertage
in Deutschland. Wir haben ein bisschen was
vorbereitet, einige Dinge, die wir besprechen
wollen. Und diejenigen, die jetzt live zuschauen
auf YouTube: Ihr könnt uns Fragen schreiben
und hoffentlich haben wir am Ende so fünf oder
zehn Minuten, um ein paar davon zu beantworten.
Am besten ruhig Fragen, die zum Thema passen,
also zu Festen und Feiertagen in Deutschland.
Und ihr müsst die nur einmal reinschreiben,
Isi ist nämlich wieder hinter den Kulissen
und sortiert das ein bisschen und es geht
nichts verloren. Also, wir freuen uns, wenn ihr
uns im Chat schreibt. Und Janusz, ich dachte,
wir starten mal mit einer Audionachricht, die
uns Tatiana aus der Slowakei geschickt hat.
Hallo Cari und Manuel! Ich habe eine Frage: Ich
bin neugierig, ob man feiert den Namenstag in
Deutschland. Und wenn ja, dann: Ist es,
ist die Feier gleich wie der Geburtstag
oder ist sie kleiner oder größer oder ist sie
überall alle unterschiedlich? Bitte erzählt uns
ein bisschen darüber und vielen Dank im
Voraus und liebe Grüße aus der Slowakei.
Ja. Also ich muss sagen, ich habe eigentlich
überhaupt keine Verbindung und auch relativ wenig
Wissen über den Namenstag, aber ich weiß,
dass das bei dir ein bisschen anders ist,
oder? (Bei mir, ja.) Weißt
du, wann dein Namenstag ist?
Ja, genau. Namenstag gab es bei mir, als ich noch
in Polen gelebt habe, selbstverständlich da schon
sehr früh. Schon in der Schule marschierten
wir zur Schule mit einer großen Tüte voller
Bonbons und die Bonbons wurden dann ausgeteilt
in der Klasse. Und alle sangen etw… ich weiß gar
nicht was, weil, ja, nicht "Happy Birthday",
aber irgendwas hat die Klasse dann für uns
gesungen und so feierten wir unseren Namenstag.
Und später war Namenstag so ausgesprochen eine
riesige Party. Der Geburtstag wohingegen war
in Polen immer mehr so ein familiäre(s) Fest,
viel kleiner. Darüber erzählen wir noch, aber den
Namenstag hat man gefeiert und das war so ganz
lustig, als man zwischen den Hochhäusern in, auf
meine Siedlung marschiert hat (ist), dann gab es
irgendwo immer einen Namenstag und man hörte dann
das Gesinge und man hörte die vielen Menschen,
die da in so einer kleinen Wohnung (eine)
riesige Party gefeiert haben. Und das war, ja,
das gehörte zu der polnischen Kultur einfach dazu.
Und erst, als ich nach Deutschland kam und dann
darauf bestanden habe bei meinen neuen Freunden,
dass sie meinen Namenstag auch mitfeiern, erfuhr
ich eigentlich, dass das ein kirchlicher Feiertag
ist, dass man dann nicht den eigenen Namen feiert,
sondern den Namen des Namensgeber(s), also den
Heiligen, von dem du deinen Namen bekommst,
ja? Und den du auch anbeten kannst, wenn
du in irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten kommst.
Und das fand ich sehr lustig und trotzdem
verlange ich zumindest von Cari immer noch,
dass mein Namenstag zumindest insoweit gefeiert
wird, dass ich ein Geschenk bekomme, bitte sehr.
Ja, das habe ich schon ein paar Mal mitbekommen,
aber ja. Also du bist in Polen aufgewachsen,
das ist gut, dass du das noch mal gesagt
hast. Und klar, es ist … Polen ist ein sehr
katholisches Land immer noch und deswegen
hat das da so einen Stellenwert. Ich habe,
ehrlich gesagt, noch nie eine katholische
Familie in Deutschland getroffen, die den
Namenstag feiert, aber wahrscheinlich
gibt es das auch in Deutschland. Das
ist ja keine nationale Frage, sondern
eine religiöse Frage so ein bisschen, ne?
Ja, das ist so ein … im Jahre, im Laufe der
hunderten Jahre verwächst das und dann ist es,
dann wird es ein Teil von der allgemeinen Kultur,
die alle feiern. Und so ist es auch mit sämtlichen
anderen großen christlichen Feiern in Polen.
Das sind, das sind Tage, die alle feiern,
auch die Atheisten. Es gibt sehr, sehr viele
Atheisten in Polen, ja? Nicht umsonst hatten
wir fünfzig Jahre kommunistische Vorherrschaft.
Und da sind ja ganze Generationen atheistisch
erzogen worden und es ist Quatsch, wenn man sagt,
dass Polen zu neunzig Prozent katholisch ist. Das
ist Polen nicht, aber Polen feiert und mag
die christliche Kultur, wobei jeder sich
das auslegt, wie er will, ja? Also christliche
Kultur bla bla. Bedeutet nicht viel, aber die
Leute schämen sich das (dafür) nicht. Also die
sagen: "Jaja, unsere Kultur ist christlich."
Ja. Und in Deutschland sind sehr, sehr viele
Feiertage ja zumindest im Kern auch christliche
Feiertage, kommen wir gleich noch auf die
Feiertage zu sprechen, die es in Deutschland gibt.
Und das, obwohl mittlerweile fast vierzig Prozent
der Deutschen konfessionslos sind, also auch
keiner Konfession, keiner Religionsgemeinschaft
mehr angehören, auch wenn viele trotzdem privat
an Gott glauben. Ja, aber insofern spielt bei uns
in Deutschland der Geburtstag eine größere Rolle
als der Namenstag, würde ich mal allgemein sagen.
Ist eigentlich überall so. Was verbindest du denn
mit deinem Geburtstag? Feierst du jedes Jahr
groß? Wie stehst du zu diesem Fest "Geburtstag"?
Ja, mittlerweile wird das immer skurriler,
aber so: "Yeah, mein nächster Geburtstag,
einundsechzig, juhu!" Okay, aber bei mir in meiner
Familie gab es ganz besondere Traditionen, weil
meine arme Mama hatte einen Unfall, kurz bevor sie
mich geboren hat, und sie ist bei der Geburt fast
gestorben. Es war so eine riesige Geschichte, die
man sich in meiner Familie immer wieder erzählt
hat. Und deshalb haben wir diesen Geburtstag immer
auch als den Tag meiner Mutter gefeiert und ich
finde das vollkommen richtig. Also, du kommst da
als so ein kleines Baby, das nichts von der Welt
weiß noch und bist so ziemlich uninvolviert in das
ganze Geschehen, aber deine Mama hatte so einiges
erlebt an dem Tag. Also, wenn du den nächsten
Geburtstag feierst, dann kauft mal etwas deiner
Mama, ja? Sei dankbar dafür und nicht immer nur
so: "Geschenk, Geschenk, ich habe Geburtstag!"
Ja, das finde ich eine sehr schöne Idee und eine
schöne Perspektive und passt auch gut zu einem
Punkt, der mir dazu einfällt. Und das ist, glaube
ich, schon ein bisschen speziell in Deutschland.
Also ich weiß zum Beispiel, dass so in der
nordamerikanischen Tradition, USA und so weiter,
dass man da halt als Geburtstagskind, auch
wenn man schon erwachsen ist, den Tag über im
Mittelpunkt steht und verwöhnt wird von allen und
Geschenke bekommt. Und in Deutschland ist das als
Kind definitiv auch so, aber als Erwachsener dreht
sich das plötzlich so ein bisschen. Und ich weiß,
dass man in den meisten Firmen, wenn man selbst
Geburtstag hat, ist es Tradition oder so der gute
Anstand, dass man selbst dann was mitbringt und
den anderen einen ausgibt. Also man selbst bringt
dann Kuchen mit, damit alle anderen Kuchen
haben, obwohl man ja selbst Geburtstag hat.
Oder man lädt alle anderen zu einem Drink ein
an seinem eigenen Geburtstag. Kennst du das?
Ja, das kenne ich nicht, weil ich habe,
glaube ich, nie in so einem Umfeld
gearbeitet, aber ich erinnere mich,
als du deine Geburtstage gefeiert hast. Und
du hast sie … ja, die sind von deiner Mama
organisiert worden und die sind also ausgesprochen
deutsch dann gefeiert worden. Und ich war ein bis…
Ausgesprochen deutsch.
Ja, in der deutschen Kleinstadtkultur
sozusagen. Aber ich war, ja,
ich war so ein bisschen befremdet, so, weil in
Polen feiert man das n… man lässt die Kinder
feiern und das ist es. Und (die) Kinder
freuen sich und feiern miteinander und
die Eltern sitzen dann in der Ecke vom Garten
und trinken ihr Bier, ja? Und beide Parteien
haben (eine) sehr gute Zeit. Und bei dir war
das so, das war dein Tag, alle sprangen rum,
um dich herum. Die Erwachsenen liefen herum
und brachten alles und organisierten Spiele
und spielten mit den Kindern. Und ich dachte:
"Alter, ich will mich in der Ecke hinsetzen
und mein Bier trinken und die Kinder, lasst die
Kinder in Ruhe, lasst sie spielen, ja?" Und ja.
Ja. Also, Janusz — für die, die
das noch nicht wussten und sich
jetzt denken können — ist mein Papa, ist mein
Vater. Und was ich trotzdem dazu sagen muss,
ist, dass du der Star warst auf
allen Kindergeburtstagen, ne? Also.
Oh, das ist lieb.
Das klingt jetzt so, als hättest du keinen Spaß
gehabt, aber du hast die Geburtstage schon schön
mitgemacht und Topfschlagen und was es da alles
für Spiele gibt als Kind, alles mitgemacht.
Ja, das war wunderschön. Und ich
lache jetzt darüber natürlich,
weil die Polen sind da im Grunde
weniger fürsorglich, ja? Also,
kümmern sich weniger um ihre Kinder, aber
dass man sich um euch so viel gekümmert hat,
das ist doch viel schöner. Das ist auch
etwas sehr, sehr Wertvolles, ganz klar, ja.
Ja. Ja, dann gibt es natürlich Weihnachten.
Wir haben schon öfter im Podcast und auch in
Easy German Videos über Weihnachten berichtet und
geredet, deswegen würde ich einfach vorschlagen,
wir verlinken in den Show Notes diese Episoden
und diese Videos und halten einfach fest,
dass in den allermeisten deutschen Familien
Weihnachten so das Familienfest ist, ne? Da kommt
die Familie zusammen, man isst und verbringt
ein paar Tage zusammen. Dann gibt es Ostern,
das ist ja eigentlich das höchste christliche
Fest. Und ich denke, für die Menschen,
die wirklich praktizierende, gläubige Christen
sind, ist das auch wichtig und sie gehen in die
Kirche. Aus meiner Sicht: Ich verbinde Ostern
auch wieder hauptsächlich mit meiner Kindheit,
weil man als Kind in Deutschland zu Ostern eben
Süßigkeiten oder Eier sucht, im Garten oder in
der Wohnung, je nach Wetter, genau. Was hast du
für eine Beziehung zu Ostern? Feierst du das?
Nein, nein, nicht wirklich. Also, ich erinnere
mich als Kind auch, dass ich mit meinem Opa die
Eier gesucht habe, aber ich glaube, aus dem ganzen
christlichen Glauben war mir diese Sache als
Allererstes suspekt. So, ja, "wir sind Christen
und wir feiern jetzt das Kaninchen und die Eier,
die gemalten Eier", was ist denn das? Und das
war, in der Zeit, wo ich … Heute verstehe ich
das. Das sind ja natürlich, wir wissen, wie
es dazu gekommen ist. Die Kirche hat damals
die heidnischen Feste übernommen quasi. Und sie
haben das aber auf möglichst freundl… friedliche
Weise gemacht und so haben sie auch Elemente von
den (der) heidnischen Kultur einfach mitgenommen.
Komm, natürlich, ja? Eier, ach, toll! Kaninchen
versteckt Eier? Ganz klar, wir nehmen das einfach,
ja? Aber als Jugendliche(r) dachte ich mir:
"Was ist das für ein Quatsch? Was ist das für
eine Verballhornung? Was soll das?", ja?
Und das war einer der, so, Elemente, die,
wo ich angefangen habe, etwas kritisch über den
christlichen Glauben nachzudenken, glaube ich.
Und gerade vor der Episode hatten wir beide so ein
bisschen nachdenken müssen: Was wird da eigentlich
gefeiert? Die Eier und die Kaninchen, das
wissen wir, aber was steckt dahinter eigentlich?
Na ja, komm. Also wir wussten
schon, worum es bei Ostern geht,
wir hatten nur nicht mehr genau im Kopf, an
welchem Tag jetzt genau was geschehen ist.
Okay.
Also das möchte ich doch schon anmerken. So
ganz so ungebildet sind wir nicht. Okay, ja,
jetzt müssen wir so ein bisschen schauen, weil
ich wollte unbedingt auch noch mit dir über die
Feiertage reden in Deutschland. Also Feiertage
— müssen wir erst mal festhalten — sind Tage,
an denen frei ist, an denen nicht gearbeitet
wird in Deutschland. Das ist quasi so wie
Urlaubstage. Urlaubstage kann man sich
als Arbeitnehmer selbst aussuchen. Und
was meinst du, wie viele Urlaubstage haben
die meisten Deutschen? Hast du eine Idee?
Oh, ich würde schätzen, so um … zwanzig Tage.
Ja, zwanzig Tage ist das gesetzliche Minimum,
also vier Wochen. Der Durchschnitt ist
aber achtundzwanzig Tage, also knapp sechs
Wochen ist so das, was die meisten Deutschen
an Urlaubsanspruch haben. Und Feiertage
sind eben gesetzlich geregelt. Die Tage,
an denen alle frei haben, bis auf bestimmte
Berufsgruppen wie zum Beispiel die Feuerwehr,
Notdienst, Krankenhäuser, Restaurants. Und
tatsächlich gibt es dazu eine Regelung in
unserem Grundgesetz — ich habe es
mal mitgebracht — und ich fand das
so schön. Und zwar steht im Grundgesetz:
"Der Sonntag und die staatlich anerkannten
Feiertage bleiben als Tage der Arbeitsruhe
und der seelischen Erhebung geschützt."
Na toll. Und hast du jetzt gegoogelt, was
seelische Erhebung eigentlich bedeuten soll?
Ja, habe ich. Ich habe im Duden
geschaut und das Wort "Erhebung",
eine der Definitionen dafür … also
eine Erhebung kann ja so ein …
Darf ich raten?
… Hügel sein oder ein Berg. Ja,
was glaubst du, was heißt es noch?
Weil man hebt das Glas mit dem Bier
dann. Und das ist die seelische Erhebung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das der Gedanke dahinter war.
Also im Duden steht "seelisches Glücksgefühl".
Ah ja. (Also an Feiertagen
…) Elevated. Man ist so …
Richtig, genau. Das ist eigentlich die
Bedeutung, ne? Also "Elevation" ist das Gleiche
wie "Erhebung". Ja, also, jetzt habe ich mal ein
paar Fragen für dich. Also erst mal ist es ja so,
dass, die Feiertage sind in der Kompetenz der
Bundesländer. Wir haben ja den Föderalismus in
Deutschland und jedes Bundesland kann selbst
entscheiden, welche Tage gesetzliche Feiertage
sind und welche nicht. Was schätzt du denn, wie
viele Feiertage gibt es? Also, was ist die Spanne?
Wow! Ich weiß es nicht, aber
ich nutze jetzt die Gelegenheit,
um etwas zu erzählen, was mich total
fasziniert. Und zwar in Spanien,
im Mittelalter, war jeder zweite Tag
ein Feiertag. Ein christlicher Feiertag,
jeder zweite. Ist ein Halbwissen, ich
habe das nie nachgeprüft, nirgendwo.
Sehr gefährliches Halbwissen.
Aber die christliche Kultur wurde,
war da so gefeiert und so überwichtig,
dass man jeden Ta… jeden zweiten Tag zu
irgendeinem Heiligen gebetet und gefeiert
hat. Ungeprüft. Ihr müsstet das vielleicht
prüfen, ja? Ich kann mir aber vorstellen,
dass das so ähnlich war. Und in Deutschland, lass
mich nachdenken. Wir haben zweiundfünfzig Wochen
im Jahr, dann mindestens zwanzig davon … nee,
fünfzehn davon sind Feiertage, fünfzehn im Jahr.
Das ist sehr optimistisch gedacht. Es sind
zwischen neu… es sind zwischen zehn und
vierzehn Tage, je nach Bundesland. Neun gelten
bundesweit, also in jedem Bundesland. Und es
ist sehr interessant also, man sieht da so ein
Nord-Ost-Gefälle, Nord-Süd-Gefälle. Im Norden
gibt es tendenziell weniger Feiertage und im
Süden, also zum Beispiel Bayern hat mit zwölf
Tagen die meisten … habe ich gerade zwölf gesagt
oder vierzehn? Es sind zwölf, zehn bis zwölf. Dann
gibt es aber noch bestimmte Städte, wo es anders
ist. Also in Augsburg, einer Stadt in Bayern, da
gibt es sogar vierzehn Feiertage. Also so gibt es
da Unterschiede. Welche Feiertage kennst du denn?
Ja, ich freue mich über diese Frage, weil ich
habe einen Feiertag, den ich ganz besonders mag,
alleine wegen dem (des) Namen(s) und dann
auch wegen der populären Verballhornung von
diesem Namen. Und zwar, es gibt einen Buß- und
Bettag, also man soll büßen und beten. Und alle
Deutschen freuen sich auf diesen Feiertag
und nennen es "Bett- und Knutschtag", ja.
Echt? (Ja.) Alle Deutschen? Also ich habe
das noch nie gehört, aber okay. Das ist
allerdings keiner der Feiertage, die in allen
Bundesländern gelten, also den gibt es nur in
manchen Bundesländern. Welche kennst du denn
noch, die so überall in Deutschland gelten?
Natürlich Weihnachten und …
Ja, erster und zweiter Weihnachtsfeiertag.
Genau. Und dann Ostertage. Heißt das Ostertage?
Ja, also es gibt den Ostermontag und
den Karfreitag. Die sind in
ganz Deutschland Feiertage.
Ja. Und den Rest kenne ich überhaupt
nicht. Nicht einen einzigen könnte ich
jetzt hier nennen, nicht mal, wenn ich mir
was ausdenken könnte, dann … was wäre das?
Na ja, komm! Also es gibt ja noch
… was passiert nach Silvester?
Marias Himmelfahrt.
Nein, nach Silvester ist Neujahr, ist der erste
Januar, Neujahr. Das ist auch ein Feiertag.
Das ist christlich?
Das ist, glaube ich, nicht christlich. Nein,
es geht ja jetzt um die deutschen Feiertage,
also nicht nur die christlichen.
Ach stimmt, dann, jaja.
Uns fehlen nämlich auch zwei sehr
wichtige, die nicht christlich sind.
Ja. Und das ist natürlich die deutsche Einheit.
Richtig. Und das ist tatsächlich der einzige
Feiertag, der nicht nur in allen Bundesländern
gilt, sondern auch vom Bund definiert ist. Also
das ist wirklich quasi vorgeschrieben bundesweit,
während alle anderen … theoretisch könnte sich
jedes Bundesland entscheiden, das nicht zu feiern.
Am dritten oder am neunten Oktober, oder?
Dritter Oktober. (Dritter Oktober, ja.)
Genau. Und dann gibt es noch einen Tag,
an dem in Berlin zumindest früher immer
viel Krawall war und Demonstrationen.
Der erste Mai.
Der erste Mai, der Tag der Arbeit, genau.
Das sind eigentlich die wichtigsten großen.
Es gibt noch ein paar besondere Feiertage und
das ist auch ganz interessant, weil es gibt ja
diese Diskussion in Deutschland: Sollten wir
wirklich so viele christliche Feiertage haben,
wenn Deutschland doch aus vielen Religionen
besteht und auch viele Menschen nicht religiös
sind? Und so führen jetzt einige Bundesländer
neue Feiertage ein. Und Berlin hat tatsächlich
erst vor Kurzem einen neuen Feiertag
eingeführt. Weißt du, welcher das ist?
Nein, aber ich kann mir denken, ich würde, ich
… spontan würde ich denken, wenn … natürlich
brauchen die Muslime ihren eigenen Feiertag,
also dass sie dazugehör(en), gerade in Berlin,
das steht außer Frage einfach. Und wir
sollen mit denen auch feiern. Das wäre schön,
aber ich glaube, der erste Feiertag müsste
doch der jüdischen Kultur gelten eigentlich,
die verloren gegangen ist. Und so könnte ich
mir denken, dass es irgendein jüdische(s)
Chanukka-Fest oder irgendetwas offiziell
gefeiert wird in Deutschland, ist doch …
Ja, ist eine schöne Idee und ein
schöner Gedanke. Und tatsächlich,
das hat Cari mir heute noch erzählt,
gibt es diese Diskussion: Warum wird
eigentlich in Deutschland nicht der Tag der
Befreiung vom Nationalsozialismus gefeiert
wie in vielen anderen Ländern und wie es Berlin
tatsächlich einmalig letztes Jahr gemacht hat,
weil der fünfundsiebzigste Jahrestag war vom,
von der Befreiung vom Nationalsozialismus. Aber
der neue regelmäßige Feiertag in Berlin
ist der Frauentag. Es geht um die Frauen.
Am achten März?
Ja! Hast du das jetzt gegoogelt oder
wie hast du das jetzt so schnell …?
Nein, nein. In Polen ist das seit immer
ein … das ist von den Kommunisten,
von den Russen ein eingeführter
"internationaler Frauentag",
achter März. Und mittlerweile sind wir so weit,
glaube ich, in Polen, dass wir schon anfangen,
langsam diesen Tag zu belächeln, weil es ist
auch ein bisschen bescheuert, also dann …
Vorsicht, Vorsicht. Mach dir keine
Feinde, Feindinnen jetzt hier.
Nein, nein, nein. Die Frauen, die Feministinnen,
die brauchen keinen Frauentag. Wir haben ein
ganzes Frauenjahr. Jahr für Jahr ist ein
Frauenjahr und die brauchen keinen Tag,
ja? Dann haben wir einen Tag für Hunde,
einen Tag für Bäume und einen Tag für
Frauen. Was soll das? Ich bin nicht dafür,
habe es nie, habe es immer ignoriert. Ich
habe nie Blumen Frauen geschenkt an dem
Frauentag. Lächerlich! Mache ich nicht.
Dafür an allen anderen Tagen des Jahres. (Ja,
genau.) Dafür bist du bekannt. Okay, so, also,
ich schaue grad hier in unsere Notiz und Isi
hat schon einige Fragen gesammelt. Sie merkt an,
dass sie in Augsburg mal gearbeitet hat und viel
frei hatte, weil es da so viele Feiertage gab.
Also, ich würde sagen, wir fangen mal an
mit unserem zweiten und letzte(n) Segment.
Und unsere erste Frage kommt von Francisco. Hat
jetzt nicht so viel mit Feiertagen zu tun, obwohl
ein bisschen. Und zwar, er schreibt: "Was soll ich
tun, wenn meine Nachbarn am Sonntag laut sind?"
Erdulden, ja?
Erdulden? (Genau.) Nichts.
Nichts, nichts tun. Einfach Kopfhörer an
(auf) oder keine Ahnung, gehe spazieren.
Wir haben jetzt Corona-Zeit. Wir
müssen diese Momente respektieren,
wo die Leute doch dann noch
ein bisschen feiern, ja.
Dann gibt es mehrere Fragen von
Iona, von Biz und auch von Isi,
dass es anscheinend in England einen "Pancake
Day" gibt, also einen Pfannkuchen-Tag. Habe
ich noch nie gehört. Das feiert man am
Dienstag nach Rosenmontag. Kennst du das?
Nein, aber ich finde, das ist doch so typisch süß
und es ist, gerade diesen Sinn für Humor liebe
ich an England so sehr. Natürlich, wir haben ja
einen Frauentag, also warum nicht Pfannkuchen-Tag?
Okay, YT schreibt: "Hallo Janusz und
Manuel, was ist euer Lieblingsfest?"
Habe ich nicht, aber …habe ich nicht.
(Ich glaube …) Caris Geburtstag.
Warum?
Weiß ich nicht, weil ich muss
dann nichts organisieren und …
Du musst da nichts organisieren?
… stehe so ein bisschen an der Seite
und die Party ist trotzdem toll.
Okay. Die Antwort ist akzeptiert, die nehmen wir
so. Also ich weiß auch, ich habe auch, ich habe,
als Kind habe ich natürlich meinen Geburtstag
geliebt, aber mittlerweile bedeutet mir mein
Geburtstag auch nicht mehr so viel. Ich glaube,
ich mag einfach … ich glaube, ich mag Weihnachten,
weil das schon so eine Zeit ist, wo man so
ein bisschen sich die Zeit nimmt und die
Ruhe nimmt und auch Zeit miteinander verbringt.
Ich mag Weihnachten. "Bis wann habt ihr an den
Weihnachtsmann geglaubt?" Hast du überhaupt an
den Weihnachtsmann geglaubt? Gab es das in Polen?
Ja, aber ich habe nie an den Weihnachtsmann
geglaubt. Das interessierte mich nicht und dann
hatten wir eine Feier mit einem alten,
dicken, nach Alkohol stinkenden Mann,
der als Weihnachtsmann verkleidet
war, gehabt und … Ich meine,
ich war klein und nicht besonders hell
und so, aber das k(o)nnte man sehen,
dass das ein alter, dicke(r), nach Alkohol
stinkende(r) Mann ist und kein Weihnachtsmann.
Okay. Dave, das passt ganz gut
hier zu deinem Gelächter über die,
diese besonderen Feiertage. Dave möchte wissen:
Welchen neuen Feiertag würden wir einführen,
wenn wir einen Feiertag einführen könnten?
Einen Konfitüren-Tag vielleicht, oder einen
Espresso-Kaffee… Koffeinfreien-Kaffee-Tag,
keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht wirklich, aber
ich hätte gerne eine Kommission gegründet,
die sich das neu überlegt. Und es gibt
bestimmt so Eckdaten in unserer Kultur,
(an) die wir uns wieder erinnern können,
und zwar nicht nur die traurigen, ja,
weil das übt man hier in Deutschland schon
sehr fleißig und das ist auch richtig so,
aber auch so Sachen, die uns freuen, wie zum
Beispiel: Der alte Gottlieb Benz erfindet ein
Auto. Juhu! Oder … keine Ahnung. So tolle Sachen
und die könnten wir so ganz gechillt feiern, ja.
Und ich denke auch, das, was du vorhin gesagt
hast, dass vielleicht die Feiertage ein bisschen
besser verteilt werden könnten und nicht so
ganz auf eine Religion fokussiert sein könnten.
Also ich würde sie versuchen, diverser
zu machen, dass mehr Menschen sich auch
angesprochen fühlen und ja, in irgendeiner Weise
repräsentiert werden. Und apropos Repräsentation:
Wir haben ein real-time Feedback bekommen,
dass der Frauentag — das ist vielleicht ein
bisschen auch falsch herübergekommen —
natürlich nicht, da geht es nicht darum,
dass wir zelebrieren, dass es Frauen gibt
oder dass, wie toll das ist, wie Frauen sind,
sondern es geht um die Rechte von Frauen,
ja? Also es geht um, ja, um Equality,
ja? Um Gleichberechtigung und um Rechte. Und ich
denke, das war, ist und war ein langer Kampf und
insofern ist das schon auch gerechtfertigt, dass
es da einen Feiertag zu gibt. Und ich würde das
auch so unterstützen und ich würde sagen, du
bist überstimmt und kannst dir das Feedback …
Und ich akzeptiere das.
… sicher auch noch anles… durchlesen und anhören,
da kriegen wir sicher ein paar E-Mails zu. Also
das ist ja das Schöne am Podcasten. Okay, letzte
Frage. Boah, wir haben noch mega viele. Wir werden
uns die speichern und versuchen, später drauf
zurückzukommen. Kann mich nicht entscheiden.
Also Silvester haben wir auch schon öfter drüber
gesprochen. Ich würde sagen … eine, das ist eine
technische, aber gute Frage: Wenn man die dreißig
Urlaubstage nimmt, sind dann die Weihnachts… also
die, wie sagt man? Die Feiertage auch, gehen
die davon quasi ab? Nein, die sind natürlich
zusätzlich. Ich habe auch eine Statistik, wie
viele, also die Urlaubstage und die Feiertage
zusammen, wie viele das sind je nach Land. Und
da ist Deutschland tatsächlich gar nicht so
weit oben. Also, Brasilien, habe ich zum Beispiel
gesehen, hat dreißig Urlaubstage und dann noch mal
elf Feiertage. Also, da kann Deutschland auf jeden
Fall noch aufholen, ja. Und Dahai, okay, das ist
das Letzte: "Feiert ihr Mittwoch als Bergfest?"
Bergfest ist so ein Begriff, wenn man in der Mitte
angekommen ist und ja, weiß ich nicht, ob wir
das als … Siehst du deinen Mittwoch als Bergfest?
Ja. Ich habe das allerdings vor Kurzem erfahren,
diesen Begriff, vor drei Monaten und … Ja und
ich habe mich gefreut, so, "wow!" Ich wusste
das die ganze Zeit nicht. Ich wusste schon,
dass man, dass die Studenten in Münster
immer mittwochs abends gesoffen haben,
aber ich wusste diesen Hintergrund nicht und
diesen Namen nicht. Und dann haben wir eine
Zeit lang hier auch immer mehr, mehr zufällig
als … da war nicht eine Absicht dahinter,
aber zufälligerweise ergab sich immer am Mittwoch
so eine kleine Feier und dann lachten wir darüber,
dass das … oder ich lachte darüber,
dass das der (das) Bergfest ist.
Ja. Das Bergfest, wo die
Hälfte der Woche geschafft ist.
Genau.
Okay, ja, vielen Dank, dass
du dabei warst, Janusz. Und …
Ist das jetzt schon zu Ende? Ich dachte …
Das ist jetzt schon zu Ende, aber die gute
Nachricht für alle, die das nicht wissen:
Wir machen das hier dreimal die Woche, zwar
nicht auf YouTube, aber in jeder Podcast-App.
Wenn ihr nach Easy German sucht, findet ihr
unseren Podcast. Oder auf easygerman.fm,
da sind auch alle Links. Und wenn ihr zu dieser
Episode und zu allen Episoden ein Transkript haben
möchtet und eine interaktive Vokabelhilfe, wo ihr
die Übersetzung seht von den aktuellen Wörtern,
die wir gerade sagen, dann werdet ein
Mitglied von uns: patreon.com/easygerman.
Und für ein paar Euro oder Dollar oder
Pounds im Monat könnt ihr Mitglied sein,
unsere Arbeit unterstützen und bekommt diese
Dinge. Das war es. Vielen Dank! Bis bald, Janusz.
Danke sehr!
Ciao.